nö
hier meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer kleinen map ihr
seht wahrscheinlich schon rechts am rand
und da ist auch der crafter alburg und
beispiel wir heute zusammen minecraft
cas-urteil zwei eventuell kennt der ein
oder andere dieses spiel
wer ist es oder wer bin ich also nicht
dass wer bin ich was jeder youtuber
macht sondern diese richtig viel mit den
komischen teil mit den komischen
menschen also es wird nachher so sein
ich kriege einen kopf zugeteilt den muss
max erraten und max bekommt ein kopf
zugeteilt und den muss ich erwarten und
wir haben dann jeder seine ganz große
platte von ganz vielen köpfen und dann
müssen wir uns gegenseitig fragen
stellen und immer wenn man mit ja
antwortet darf man der nur noch mal und
wir zeigen es euch einfach beim spielen
so freunde geht wird ihr die ihr seht
jetzt hier schon werden die ein oder
anderen köpfe kreiert also wir haben wir
beispielsweise so ganz fiktionale köpfe
wie irgendwie so weit dass es gar nicht
gibt also sind dann alles youtuber köpfe
oder irgendwie von natur oder von dem
mob oder so und das hier seht ihr jetzt
ist der kopf den max erraten muss und
hier einer von diesen köpfen den hatten
max auf der anderen seite da seht ihr
max namen und da ist der kopf den ich
erraten muss und das ist nämlich einer
von denen hier ok freunde und ihr habt
schon gesehen ist your turn und dann
steht ihr dialekt us kongess also wenn
ich jetzt mache das macht man meistens
am ende wenn man sich sicher ist welchen
kopf man hat aber ich mache erst mal so
und jetzt seht ihr schon bekomme ich
eine axt und ich bekomme einen slum blog
das ist jetzt nämlich so wenn ich gleich
einen blog hier beispielsweise kaputt
mache kann ich den standort wieder
hinsetzen und sagen oh hab ich mich
vertan macht erstmal nach dem motto
learning by doing also machen drei
runden und max bin ich ein mensch also
du ja die messe kopf oder ich meinen
kopf du bist du bist ein mensch findet
ein mensch okay wenn ich ein mensch bin
dann kann ich auf jeden fall schon mal
die ganzen sachen hier wegpacken die
hundertprozentig kein mensch sind
was ist denn das für viele menschen wird
q maske zum beispiel
als gut danke und dann macht es die
fragen mit ja beantwortet hat darf jetzt
noch mal fragen habe ich eine brille
nein hast du nicht nein habe ich nicht
möchte dann kann ich jetzt alle personen
die hier eine brille aufhaben kann ich
jetzt schon mal löschen und ja jetzt
erwachsen gesagt hat muss sich die achse
ist einfach hinschmeißen und jetzt ist
max soll und jetzt kann man sich
entscheiden ob er fragen will oder ob er
ihn was raten will fragen entschieden so
spontan raten jetzt am anfang für die
bisschen früh
aber da bin ich ein mensch nutzer du
bist ein mensch habe ich also ist meine
hautfarbe normal
ja ja die ganz in grün wesen weg macht
übrigens freunde wenn ihr wollt dass
sich das eventuell nicht nur gegen max
mache sondern auch mal gegen paar andere
youtuber oder so könnt ihr mit ein wenn
die kommentare schreiben
ich hätte das gedacht aber ich weiß
nicht vielleicht weil es immer so sven
sind natürlich immer andere köpfen
anderer leute dabei die das zocken aber
vielleicht habt ihr doktor bin ich
männlich
das kann man echt nicht so genau
beantworten
ok andere frage stellen dann einfach
erstellen eine andere frage
trage keinen bart trägt keinen bart ist
der bart von back to black und ja das
ist ganz blöder kopf jetzt erstmal weg
wegschmeißen ins besucher lockte
natürlich
habe ich blaue augen
ja das blaue augen habe ich eine
kopfbedeckung ja habe ich schwarze haare
nein aber ich musste ich eigentlich
eigentlich müsstest du oder ich liege
falsch ich weiß ja nicht
ich glaub ich riskiert und raten lieber
nochmal ist mein gesicht von etwas
bedeckt sei es die sonnenbrille und
mundschutz ist es ja du kannst nicht
mehr gewinnen
vergessen müssen im vorfeld zu falsche
darauf hat mich jetzt gepokert
okay du hast du hast eine bedeckung
irgendwo am kopf du hältst noch mal
fragen dürfen
ich weiß also freundet man das spiel
nicht richtig verstanden normalerweise
ein max frage gestellt und ich sage ja
dann dafür noch mal fragen
aber da ich jetzt gewinne ich gäste dann
mal eben und zwar muss jetzt die karten
nehmen wenn ich der ich habe gewonnen
genau hervor nur in runde zwei freunde
die köpfe den tisch ziehen
wir haben das ist der kopf dmax und ihn
schwer
das wird für mich richtig chaotisch zum
fragen beantworten
naja du bist du bist blaue okay ja ich
werde natürlich erst mal raten was
andere wertung wie immer die frage bin
kein mensch der kein mensch also ein
mensch mensch ist das was nicht
irgendein blog oder monster oder so ist
etwas was man ganz auf den ersten blick
erkennen kann das ist ein menschen
bin ich ein blog frage ich mal nein das
bin ich kein blog also fragt doch
einfach bin ich etwas anderes als ein
blog
ihr müsst wissen als ich gerade ein
bisschen aggressiv bin ich am kiefer
verloren gegen sundt spaß dein
verdienten 1 0 gewonnen
ich weiß nicht ob ich dann das spiel es
hält die glasgow ging barcelona erinnert
wobei es einfach so 80 mal 80 und 85 90
beides hatte 80 ball und 15 90 110
prozent ballbesitz und trotzdem 0 1
verloren so war als sei man doch jetzt
fragt ua okay bin ich ein tier ja fragt
mir du bist das andere leben ja du bist
ein tier sage ich jetzt mal einfach
eigentlich fragen wenig in minecraft
enthalten
die raupe des m ich frag jetzt erstmals
war bin ich ein mensch kann doch nicht
sein als ob ich nicht mal ich hab zwei
fragen gestellt aber ich habe auch voll
wenig menschen hier gerade sehe ich okay
dann wäre ich jetzt einfach beraten ich
hoffe nur dass du mich nicht verhasst
ich habe schon wieder auf
egal hab ich ganz viele grüne und rote
pixel
ja was ist schildkröten drachen deswegen
war ich auch so komisch bei tier okay
das heißt freunde ich muss jetzt geraten
ich muss jetzt raten er ich habe eine
chance von 50 von 50 von 15 prozent oder
so glaube ich das ist doch nicht wahr
komm lud den hattest du wenn alles so
sammer den musst dich erwarten
du hattest du einen schnee sonst weißen
kopf mit roten augen
wer bin ich denn nicht ich bin roth
schreibt man sehen kann das gebiss in
rot-blau leute du fängst an wie immer
die anfängliche frage bin ich ein mensch
anderes jahr also wisst aber mensch dann
weg damit
das ist glaube ich die beste verein habe
ich einen bart
nee was nicht okay ich werde natürlich
auch erstmal arsten zu beginn wie ich
bin der der ganz klassische max bin ich
ein mensch sagt nicht nein das verdammt
schwer
nein ich sag nein das zwar augen aber
dass kein mensch meinten ein elefant war
schwäche hatte warf wieso doppel habe
ich etwas in meinem gesicht seiten
sondern nur okay ich gieße kannst du dir
nicht sicher
ich habe mich davor ab sich schon was ja
auch nicht ja scheiße dieses dieses
place artige ding das wollte ich erst
noch anklicken haben als du meintest mit
einer fahrstrecke von anderen komische
angeklickt wirklich mal bitte eine
sekunde nicht ich muss dir gleich wegen
sieht es so lustig aus wie du da gerade
weil wir in der luft steht
ja gut
mit minecraft cas-urteil zwei wenn ihr
lust darauf habt da ist das eventuell
mal gegen weisen die paletten oder das
meer oder irgendein anderes socke dann
schreibt mir dass man in die kommentare
ob ihr das wollt wenn es euch gefallen
hat wie ich meine bewertung freund ich
hab das wir dann wieder so ein bisschen
zusammen geschnitten damit ihr nicht
alles als mollig stehst du mir drin du
denkst du kannst alles machen aber du
kannst dich nicht ich würde einfach
sagen wenn euch gefallen hat fühle mich
über eine bewertung freuen und wir sehen
uns dann im nächsten video wieder
tschüss